hi everybody welcome back to another
edition of The Gadget Lab I am Michael
colori and I'm Nathan only about his
Giles he's the new guy I am the new guy
it's true started wired this week moved
here from Los Angeles yep yep and I am I
feel like I'm the only daughters fan in
all of San Francisco I can't believe you
just admitted that without a bad thing I
already messed enough here oh yeah well
around here it is anyway nathan has
brought a new tablet from samsung to
show us after we take a look at that
Robbie Baldwin is going to be here and
he's going to talk about zombie maps and
then alexandra is going to come on in
the end of the show and we're going to
talk about a new case for the ipad so if
you have a fancy new ipad stick around
we'll be giving one away at the end of
the show but first we have the samsung
galaxy tab 2 7 oh sorry samsung galaxy
tab 2 point 0 7 point 0 that is a
terrible product name it's it's not the
easiest to say or remember but it's
actually a follow-up to the Samsung
Galaxy Tab 7.0 plus which came out late
last year it's really really similar the
one difference you know physically is
there's not an LED flash on the back as
there was in the seven point 0 plus ok
but on the seven point O the New 22
version you get ice cream sandwich which
is fantastic ah so it's an ICS tablet it
is an ICS tablet it's the legend of
Google's Android operating system which
is a beautiful wonderful thing there are
some slight user interface changes that
I don't like as much as regular old ICS
but it doesn't really detract from you
know the experience it's still good
tablet the best part though honestly is
that it sells for 250 bucks wow so
that's a pretty hot price point yeah
it's a really good price point actually
cheaper than I thought it was going to
be and it kind of puts it just slightly
above the amazon kindle fire red oak
tablet which each go for 200 bucks and
have decidedly subpar user experiences
compared to raw ICS yeah basically M is
on in barnes noble they're taking
android they're altering it hugely so
that you can basically really stay tuned
in buying stuff from them but this is
just android as you know it and maybe
possibly love it I'm not sure okay well
I've been pretty impressed with ICS so
far yeah I like it I like ice cream
sandwich we're going to do a full review
but we have a hands-on on the gadget lab
right now cool so you can read that on
wired.com / gas lab and then there is
also a second component right to this
there was a like an ipod style player
yes I by Samsung well they're going to
have the samsung galaxy tab 2 10 point 0
which is a larger tablet as well and
then or actually i might be a 10.1 and
then there is the samsung galaxy player
3.6 and the samsung galaxy player 4.6 so
like a three and a half inch and a four
and a half inch kind of mini tab like a
ipod touch it's like the android phone
without the phone you know you've got
all your apps and they say it's
primarily a music player but you can do
everything that you can do it's like
like an ipod touch yeah this is a big
phone see hello look at it or it's a
small galaxy note yeah does it come with
the stylus there is no stylus thank god
samsung hates it when you call it stylus
they want you to call it s pen well make
it an event yesterday they're like don't
call a stylist it's different it's an S
pen's it doesn't matter that will call
it whatever the hell we want I like that
it's a stylist hell yeah well thanks for
bringing that on and welcome thanks
thanks for having here sure we're happy
to have you thanks and now we're gonna
bring out Robbie talk about zombies his
favorite topic
hey Robbie's here hi and Robbie wrote a
really interesting story on the gadget
lab this week about zombies and how to
escape certain death when the inevitable
zombie apocalypse occurs in your city
now there's a map online called the map
of the Dead is a zombie apocalypse
survival guide as far as I'm concerned
it shows a zombie danger zones which is
really any place where there's a
population P sambas come from people
where there's people it's a danger zone
but more importantly it shows you
locations for supplies military bases
gun shops which is very important when
the zombies are coming and the corridors
liquor stores it has liquor stores mall
talkative hip Funyuns bunions bunions
are they're gonna keep us all alive and
most important is cemeteries which is
the number one spawn point for zombies
at the beginning of the zombie
apocalypse okay so basically it's an
online map that shows me where to go to
get refueled where to avoid and are
there like meeting places or things like
that for other humans now they don't
they're the the developers are talking
about adding user-generated content so
you could add like hey let's all meet
here or you know this is a good place to
hide or this is where some liquor stores
are now it's using Google's api's and
some Search API so it doesn't have every
store in the area but that's kind of
good because you want to you know save
your little bodega for yourself right
right well I would appreciate the the
ability to add user generated content
because then I could bark like you know
things like phish concerts as places to
avoid get the zombie apocalypse because
you won't be able to tell which is which
well you know a lot of fish fans are
vegans you know what vegan zombies eat
great grades huh that was just a bad
excuse to put that joke in there so tell
me a little bit more about the the
cities that you identify you know I a
story identified New York Chicago and
San Francisco just kind of looked at
them and seeing how those cities can
survive well do you know the population
can survive I also look to LA but
because of all the gridlock wheels
people are all doomed
really sad Ellie I miss you please do la
is doing because everyone's just stuck
in traffic the birds and the window
that's it that's the end of that lay
there all zombies anyway well thanks
Robbie and if you want to check out his
story about the map of the Dead map of
the Dead and all the exciting and look
at all the exciting places in the world
where you can hide from zombies you can
read his story this week on the gadget
lab now let's bring on Alexander to show
us some groovy cases hey you're not
Alexandra I'm not she had to go to the
liquor store to stock up for the zombie
apocalypse oh she's been reading too
much wired Gadget Lab stories about
zombie apocalypse I think so this is to
refuel like the liquor store this is
christina christina has with her what
are these these are pad and quill ipad
cases and they're really nice we like
these a lot yeah kind of has a
reminiscent of a moleskine book approach
to the ipad case it's like a hardcover
yeah it's surrounded by wood these are
around 80 bucks we have two different
models this one folds into a stand very
nicely there's two different levels you
can have it you can have a little bit
more upright or a little bit at more of
an angle and then this one has a little
folder inside so if you've got some
papers maybe you're taking your iPad on
a presentation or something and you've
got want to show stuff on your iPad and
you have like papers to give out if you
want to carry product brochures yeah
that sort of thing also I really like
this this is kind of cool it's it's a
it's like a little pull tab that makes
it easy to pull your pull your iPad out
but it's also when it's closed it sort
of looks like an old-school bookmark so
people actually might possibly be fooled
into thinking that you're actually
carrying a book around with you I've
actually seen someone on the bus they
had a kindle and they actually carved
out a book and had their Kindle on the
inside of a book I could tell it was
homemade because they were like there
was a shine of some
on there but it was cool it took a
picture instagramed it that's pretty
awesome so they actually take an old
mole skin and carve it out just an old
book i think it was in german oh wow
well how innovative yes well if you
don't if you're not feeling particularly
innovative you can of course get these
at pad and quill and we should also
mention that the design is reminiscent
of these cases which are quite popular
which is a similar design from database
a lot of people have these as a matter
of fact when we first got the pad and
quill cases in people were like who's at
a dodo cason no it's a new pattern pill
case they're handmade Minneapolis yes
yeah very nice american-made so
considering this mixture iPad oh yeah
also we should mention these are for
ipad 3 yes they fit the ipad 2 in the
ipad 3 yeah although the ipad 3 fits
better than the ipad 2 does so if you
have a new ipad and I've had three
that's that's what that's what these are
made for and I think it's the price is a
little bit higher on three cases I think
there are a hundred but the older ones
and the ones for the other devices are a
little bit under a hundred dollars and
still affordable you for caring for your
gadgets so anyway considering this is a
literary gift or a literary gift for
yourself we have a literary trivia
question now you can we have two of
these to give away these very ones that
we have right here and you can win by
tweeting your answer to at gadget lab or
you can just leave a comment on the post
in which this podcast appears at the top
of anyway here's the question what
arthur c clarke novel shares its name
with a pink floyd song title
cheating as always is encouraged so
again if you know the answer to the
trivia question which are through see
Clark novel shares its title with a pink
floyd song tweet it gadget lab or leave
a comment on this post and that you
might win and otherwise you lose but
come back next week we'll have more
gadgets maybe an ipad case yeah maybe
another giveaway maybe something see you